him and uh what remarkable defense
in the second game because he was put
under so much pressure from the world
champion and it looks like we might be
seeing a repeat no we're not
of a game one and
we go it's gonna be a queen's gambit
declined it's game three magnus let
there be no doubt with the white pieces
yeah magnus really really wants to win
this one because he's playing his
favorite opening the catalan against
prague right now it's really helped
magnus win the title the world
championship match in uh 2021 against
janupomnishi he's been playing it
religiously ever since in these really
kind of critical battles against the top
guys in the world and that shows how
much respect carlson has for prague
choosing his best opening prague
meanwhile grabbing a pawn here
and i'm expecting magnus's light squared
bishop to develop the catalan opening is
just characterized by white slight
square bishop on the long diagonal
and even if black is a pawn up short
term long term white always has
compensation due to control in the
center of the board
and
good opening choice here by magnus i
guess prague would have predicted this
this is his main opening isn't it i mean
it's showing that magnus has given his
young opponent a lot of respect you know
he's not messing about 1a4 183 today he
really really wants to win this match
and uh win the whole title um and yeah i
mean he like you said he's prepared this
opening intensely for the world
championship match against nepo it's
probably one of the biggest preparation
openings that magnus has ever worked on
so
you you must expect him to
you know if he shows his preparation he
gets something from the opening but
prague is also incredibly well prepared
so interesting opening battle ahead and
this bishop move
is a main move i'm again i'm not too
aware of the catalan uh ins and outs but
magnus thinking a little bit now yeah
and it's known as a very ambitious move
this last bishop move uh we've talked
about it in past days uh simon this
light squad bishop for white for black
sorry is the problem piece that bishop
needs to get out of its pawn chain and
i'm surprised magnus doesn't go for the
most kind of critical continuation he
brings his queen out to a very decent
square but uh white could have hunted
down the bishop pair if he had if he uh
was so inclined
okay instead white just wants to regain
his pawn magnus and he's looking off
am i wrong there he's looking off to the
left side he was a moment ago that
normally tends to indicate that players
are just trying to recall what they've
studied before
and uh okay magnus taking your pawn back
it's level material white still has a
fantastic light squad bishop and it's up
to prague
to combat against that i was hoping
magnus would have jumped into the center
with this night normally in those types
of positions we see just chaos fighting
chess
both sides attacking each other but this
one is slightly quieter now it's prague
who sacrificed a pawn in order to get
his bishop to a better square i i just
feel magnus's last few moves show that
he wants to play a bit safer in this
game no more chaos
and you're right david i mean i see so
many drawers in the database here and it
seems to be also a grand master favorite
ding loren has played this particular
variation twice with the white pieces uh
he did lose to alexander grissook but he
did hold the draw against levon aronian
and it's just like the who's who of chas
we're both white and black we have gary
kasparov we have victor courchnoy we
have
peter lecker
and boo janji i mean it's so many
players so popular at the elite level so
this is all been worked out before yeah
and uh look at prague now he's just
closing his eyes just uh not meditating
he's more trying to recall what he
studied before this does have very solid
very good reputation for black
um this kind of defense against the
catalan opening so maybe he's just
trying to remember what the most
accurate
kind of follow-up is black needs to
regain his pawn the white pawn that's
just moved on c5 square and if he
regains it
and keeps the rest of his position
healthy he won't be in too much trouble
the poor structure will just be
symmetrical all right so
uh over the course of this 2022 season
we've gotten to know thai peru's
zimmerman he's doing all the stats for
the meltdown champions chess tour he's
one of those great guys that knows every
single formula and microsoft for the
excel or google sheets and he has done
stats now for the chances prague now has
to win
to the ftx crypto cup and he says that
just based on ratings and my game
prediction formulas
my rough odds for different results for
the last two games is
19 chance for prague to win this game
24 chance for prague to win
the last game game four which translates
to roughly a 21 chance for prague to win
the rapid which means he will win the
tournament so
21 i don't know if that's high or low
but it is a chance yeah but karya what
about our real expert i mean okay that's
true
this guy might have some degree in stats
but he's nowhere near the level of
ivanka now over to the real star
woman's gut feeling when it comes to the
stats and percentages
so what is you know real expert what can
we expect from the next two games higher
than 21 or lower you're making me blush
i think it's higher yeah yeah always
higher and 21
is so low
yes it's incredible in the last game
both simon and myself thought magnus was
going to go uh going to go and win just
80 90
you were like oh 50.
how did you do it like your banker
foresees the future
it is it's uh yeah it's definitely the
stats expert on the team so we need to
hear from you okay
what percent do you give prank to win
yeah and the rapid pressure i feel like
you can trust my stats like you could
trust that octopus that was predicting
the world
oh we should have done that by the way
and some animals
yeah
actually that would be a good thing yeah
that's true you know we have a lot of
good viewers at home yeah i'm sure that
they could also come up with some good
predictions yeah with if you have an
animal at home
make a bowl of food with uh prague's
name on one magnus game one one and name
on one and uh whatever ball the animal
eats from
well that will be the winner of the
exactly we can kind of compile as well
their stats
and there you go kaya
we'll know we'll know
it will be fate yeah and
i like it meanwhile i'm trying to think
um if we talk about classical ratings
i know we have tour ratings here but
magnus he's around he's over 28.50
pregnant
he's closing in on 2700 i think magnus
there would be expected to win
around 65 percent of the time so prague
his chances would be 35
but if we kind of assume this let's say
for argument's sake this game is a draw
prague in the final game has the white
pieces if according to classical ratings
at least he would have 35 percent in a
one-off shootout if it's just the final
game and he has white yeah it's decent
chances right oh he's definitely not out
of it as long as he doesn't lose this
game prague so this is a key game
and uh some critical moments ahead
white's queen that was under fire has
taken
a step back but the whole way back
uh i guess maybe the only safe square
for now where she won't get harassed by
some pieces this is very similar to what
prague did in the last game just dancing
around with the queen quite a lot uh
early doors and
he did regret it prague he lost a lot of
time magnus committed this mistake
yesterday against duda and uh lived to
regret or sorry two days ago against
duda and live to regret that
yeah i yeah i i'm so sure i guess it's
worth pointing out as well that this is
the first chance in the whole of the
competition that magnus has to win the
event outright you know if he wins this
game
um prague can only draw the match
and he he comes first so if he wins this
game he takes first prize so this is
this is an opportunity and he'd be well
aware of that as well with the white
pieces so it is a very big game
any other result the the tournament
continues so yeah absolutely big and uh
young christophed and geary well they
can now sit down and enjoy the drama in
this match because their match is now
finished due to winning the first two
games and a draw here in game three
means duda takes all three points and
let's hear from the winner in this match
a clean conversion on your first try
this time dude how would you summarize
your
miami adventure
yes i i think i was in pretty bad shape
so actually it's pretty nice that um
i managed to know to win
almost against anyone's um
in such state of mind
of course i'm
um i think i could have has
gotten more points for sure
but on the other hand i mean when you
win feel as much as their
do you like this format
yes i do
and it's now going to be the next major
being played in san francisco
is this something that you are
really hoping to qualify for and to play
in and
to try to almost defend your first major
title that came earlier this year in san
francisco yes
yes of course it would be nice to
qualify there
um yeah they know i'm happy you know to
play chess
it doesn't matter you know if it's if i
played in america or
i mean on antarctica i mean it's really
really the same for me so of course it's
very very cool
that
these tournaments these tournaments are
organized in nice places but um
yeah still a long way to qualify there
thank you
because before game two i was locked out
of my room yeah and maybe i would have
repeated that line that you played maybe
i had it open maybe not sure but maybe
because there was a line you should be
forking off one
and uh what you did also then i have to
castle but actually i got a decent
position i thought
yes i saw this and that's why i thought
that might make sense maybe that's my
file but actually it wasn't but uh after
g5 i should be just maybe queen of three
jupiter when you force me i was
ambitious and then i realized i just
cannot get my rookie i was trying you
know okay i shouldn't go try because
you're getting trouble i should go like
jesus
it's still like a strength of how to get
the rook you know but i cannot then you
go h5 look at six six i thought
do you like my position
yeah it was very difficult to find more
for you actually yeah i mean also yeah
and after the j3505 it's just overall
yeah
yeah it was uh unfortunate
oh i was
pretty annoyed that you didn't play in
h7 queen d1
it's very pretty it's true no i saw this
yeah first game i had some miracles
life of the chess players we're going to
interrupt duda and anish giri there i
did not understand a lot of that
notation talk
but both of them seem to be in a good
mood due to winning the match it's been
a tough tournament for anish geary he uh
ends up on uh seven points
in the tournament uh losing today's
match against duda who's been on fire
winning the three last matches but he
did have a slow start so he's not in
contention to win the tournament
we do have a move on the board magnus
thinking for a long time there yeah and
maybe a mistake long think wrong think
is the cliche magnus had a long think
and maybe
this last move i mean it makes sense
you're attacking the black queen with
your bishop but
what happens if the bishop is just
attacked what happens if a black pawn
just kicks you away what happens if the
queen moves the black queen has a bunch
of squares she can choose from she can
even come out to the side and give a
check it's a bit mysterious to me to be
honest not sure what magnus's idea is
there behind this last bishop move
i don't think it's as bad as the
evaluation bar says
but prague will be able to regain his
pawn most likely and he'll have a
healthy position
yeah i i agree with you there david i
think the evaluation part
is uh quite
ambitious on black's behalf but uh yeah
i think just move the queen i don't
think you need to initiate a set of
trades although this is a
when you kind of con consult the chess
principles it does say you know you
should perhaps trade off bishops because
white's bishop has uh taken
two
moves to get to the g5 square whereas
black will only have used one
move yeah for example if the bishops do
get traded off
if black wins this pawn back he's just
in great shape
for example if we see white's king
castle black's knight come out and take
black has two fantastic pieces in the
center no real weaknesses blackwood
castle
it's probably around level
the reason i think this isn't what the
computer wants black to do is because
the computer gives black an advantage so
maybe there's something even better than
this and uh that would make me think
that either it's the pawn stepping
forward kicking this bishop or the move
that prague has just played he does give
a check with the queen
hitting the king
magnus's idea most likely is to just
develop the white knight putting the
knight on a good square blocking the
check
and when a pawn is captured back white
will just castle
and some threats against this black
bishop in the middle of the board i'm
not sure whether black wants to allow
that capture allow that trade and if he
doesn't then he will still need one more
move to castle it is heating up actually
and we do see the bar back in white's
favor
and interesting position looks pretty
balanced on the face of things but there
will be tactics just like we saw in the
previous two games where things suddenly
turned
and there were all these kind of hidden
ideas under the surface
yeah what do you guys think still in the
balance still
prague with 21 chance today
yeah that's that's that's just not
enough i mean your fan can know so you
know you know the odds of anchor i'm
with you on this one
and um i mean this this position just
seems very rich
i think at the moment all the pieces on
the board magnus going for an exchange
of queens here which uh um
makes some sense i mean but i i i
thought developing a piece made more
sense to be honest uh i guess he's just
happy to to get the queens off the board
and
and play that position
um
it looks like it often it might come
down to black's bishop in the middle of
the board if you see that bishop it is
quite strong at the moment
this light square bishop right in the
middle of the ball but if white can
either capture it with a knight at some
point or kick it away then i think white
will have a very comfortable advantage
that's
you know just briefly looking at a
situation where i think
could be important is black's bishop in
the middle strong or weak
black is also a couple of moves from
castling as well right so it's yeah i i
kind of prefer magnus's position though
no matter what the computer says
uh so i don't know why the computer is
um
well saying that prague's doing doing
fine here but you know i mean he's
probably doing fine but not much more
than fine right yeah i mean if black is
accurate the queen's come off it's just
level yeah and very balanced it's hard
to imagine black ever having the
advantage right now just so symmetrical
the pawn structure yeah yeah nice um
yeah sorry yes i was just gonna say
black doesn't really have any bad pieces
so
i do think my radar is saying
bang on fifty percent
yeah
i mean i am worried about this bishop in
the middle i mean let's say you do
exchange queens right i mean i don't
know if we get a chance to look at this
but i mean
potentially if you do exchange queens
which is not you know the knight comes
out and
i mean look at this bishop you don't
want to allow that one to be exchanged
and if it does drop back
maybe white can move his knight
and go for some tactical ideas
potentially uh
i mean it
might be all right for black this but
you it looks a little bit scary the
night coming in maybe yeah you could
even throw that in last movie
checkmate
so there will be tactics in the end game
even if the queens come off and prague
decides okay he's not going to capture
on white's terms if we go back to the
current position
um yeah he's afraid of this bishop
actually coming under fire isn't he
simon so he dropped it back first
and uh i guess if black gets time you
want to kind of kick away white's bishop
from your half of the board you want to
somehow develop this piece but you can't
until the queen's come off because
white's queen is tying you down to this
square
and um yeah i mean if the queens
disappear and for example now if white
makes a slow move
let's say pushes a pawn then if a queen
trade happens a bishop trade happens i
think we'll see a draw
i just think
prague here black is too solid okay
very interesting it's tense this is game
three in their match uh magnus moves is
uh h pawn any surprises here no the
black knight will just happily retreat
back to a safe square
still very balanced yeah we did see
prague with great end game skills have
magnus crossing frustrated after game
two let's go to miami tanya who do you
think now will win the fdx crypto cup
it's so hard to say with the way the two
are playing back and forth the first
game progresses the second game magnus
had his chance what we do know is that
this is a big fight and that's exactly
how we like it but i think the more the
match continues the advantage shifts
towards magnus because
he just needs to actually draw the tie
breaks go into a playoff to win it so
prague needs to score in the next two
games now while it's pretty intense and
the action's hard inside uh miami is
having a lot of fun outside the playing
hall so let's catch up with some of our
spectators here and sasha sasha you're
having fun here yep i'm having a ton of
fun thanks are you are you watching the
match because i see you playing a lot of
blitz around here um i'm doing both
oh i'm trying to
and is it inspiring to see these guys
play inside uh for sure i've been
watching them every story since i've
started playing chess now you told me
you're a big magnus fan
uh yeah i am
but yeah i am all right
all right well uh all the best for your
game now we we've also got yan shrishtav
duda and neon ludwig hammer with us guys
check this out
have you asked you fellas do you get
that a lot uh apparently so yes since
ever since arriving yes everyone's
saying hi yeah nice to see you like are
you family friends i'm like okay i don't
know i'm just here to have some fun and
i am it's a lot of fun great games you
know here outside in the mix area good
games playing as well so hopefully
prague you know goes to the fourth game
has some chances and
see some more exciting games coming up
as well so
cheering for prague you're cheering for
prague what do you like about brock's
style of play uh just you know
controlled aggression very calm very
nice you know just i like everything
about him well done it's actually pretty
amazing that he's all off seventeen and
the kind of control he has over his
nerves now sristov you have come all the
way from belgium for this event correct
yeah um i had a play i played a lot of
chairs as a kid and i took like a break
for 15 years i'm back into chess in a
few months
enjoying it and have some time off now
so i thought why not make a holiday to
miami combine it with the chess it's
like a crazy trip but it's it's super
nice to be here and i'm enjoying it a
lot wow it's amazing to have you guys
here enjoy the rest of the evening
there you see miami having fun on the
weekend with lots of chess
absolutely and that really is a young
ludwig
look alike and i could also see the uh
christopher duda
wow interesting young lady comer he is
the main commentator on norwegian
television right now for tv2 they are
definitely following this action
hoping magnus carlsen will win it whilst
the whole of india is rooting for pragma
the bar is slightly over to magnus aside
but only 16 moves so far in this game a
little bit of a slower game it feels
like yeah definitely a slower game i
think the nerves are starting to kick in
for both these players magnus of course
would love to win this game would love
to kind of clinch the tournament
immediately but
it's not maybe the type of position
where he can get too excited yet um
spending a lot of time magnus as well he
took a safer choice in the opening
thus we see all the trades that are
about to happen one set of knights have
just left the board queens are about to
leave the board light square bishop's
about to leave the ball
the computer thinks white's doing pretty
well but and it's the type that could
just disappear in one move yeah i agree
david it's
so so small advantage for magnus and uh
well
we do have a caption competition for
today where we are asking you at home
to caption this picture the best caption
wins a one-year sub subscription of
chess 24 premium membership and uh well
maciac newadomski says oh no
giri will tweet about it won't he
and yi capital says when you
accidentally open with the bomb cloud
against magnus accidentally yeah i have
actually done that i was actually
wanting to put my bishop on that square
before i knew it i put the king and i
was like no way
and yeah so keep those funny suggestions
coming remember to use the hashtag
chesschamps and the funniest ones we'll
read them out on the show yep
good job you guys it's a lot of fun to
read your captions and pragnanda this is
not the reaction he hopes to have today
this was actually after a big blunder
yesterday to lose his match he's gonna
hope to have that hand in the air
celebrating his win in the fdx crypto
cup
a draw here in this game will give him
okay chances he will have to win the
last game with the white pieces yeah the
good thing for prague is that now
yesterday and that blunder that horror
kind of self-mate it's all forgotten
those the two games today the two games
we've had so far
i think they were just a great way to
banish all those demons he survived them
the score has won one he couldn't have
hoped for more he will have white in the
last game
he just needs to survive now and he's
thinking down to around six and a half
minutes
there's a few questions to answer how do
you kind of trade off on your terms as
black you don't want to allow white to
gain too much time while you make these
exchanges
white rook coming to the center of the
board i quite like that one for magnus
hinting that there might be some
checkmating ideas if white's rook can
get to the top of the board at some
point
so just some stuff to cover
for prague some small tricks here and
there maybe
but what would you guys suggest here
what would you be looking at first in
the position if you were
if you were pregnant right now i think
it is about exchanging pieces at the
moment right as you mentioned the
you're i think you're trying to equalize
as black i think that's clear because
white has castled and prague clearly
doesn't like castling today he likes
leaving his king in the middle um so he
goes for this first exchange this is
very logical and
the pawn structure is symmetrical so
there's no pawn weaknesses in either
side so if prague can just
uh exchange off a number of pieces then
he will get a quality and it will
probably be a draw meaning he's got a
chance to win with white in the last
round
but he's quite a long way from
exchanging off all the pieces and
he is behind in development and you
could see white's undeveloped knight
jumping quite dangerously into play at
some point and it just seems a little
bit dangerous for black this position to
me and
i i have to admit i don't really
understand these catalan positions as
much as i'd like to because i'm never
really sure how you go about these
exchanges so
it's certainly tricky for black to play
though white can just play natural moves
how does prague go about exchanging off
these dangerous pieces and i think
that's what he needs to be doing or even
kicking them away you know if you kick
the bishop away you can come back and
force the queen to exchange and
it's uh i i guess maybe um right uh
something like this
but
so it just seems a little bit tricky for
prague at the moment to get that
equality
and i think equality of draw would be
very happy with it definitely i mean is
it possible for practice to somehow
initiate trades now or you know maybe
try to waste some time and you know ask
put the bishop on e7 yeah so for example
now no uh it was just immediately
immediately yeah with the idea that once
bishop takes bishop happens then you can
actually
swap off queens yup and i mean if you
can get this where it's just completely
symmetrical black's king's actually
better than the white king in the center
of the board
then it's just an easy draw you just
bring your rooks to the center swap off
all the rooks and you can shake hands
or the virtual version of that the
esports version at least and ivanka yeah
bring the bishop to this square
makes some sense i'm trying to think
what else white could try here
could you try swapping the queens now
and then bringing the white knight out
but again i guess black is ready to
castle at some point
and absolutely like too many problems
yeah
uh that's
that's my thought but there's still
always that annoying night move that
simon alludes to you know jumps in that
you've got highlighted on the board so
black
isn't out of the woods yet it's like
that iceberg again that simon talked
about like it looks all quiet on the
surface but underneath there's a lot of
problems waiting in store for you yeah i
was wondering if you could do it the
other way around for example
okay he gives a check first i was
thinking swap the queens and then maybe
move the bishop but he gives a check
he's really begging for this queen
exchange he's saying to magnus please
please please swap off the queens and if
it happens right now if magnus answers
the check by capturing then at least now
i guess black is very happy and very
safe to trade off the bishops
shouldn't be too much to worry about
it's just no weaknesses simply
so this should be fine it's just about
whether you can exchange if magnus for
example runs out of this check by moving
his king or just by blocking
uh maybe you move the king i'm not sure
uh or maybe you just block with the pawn
they both look fine and again when do
you trade and when do you not it's a big
question right yeah i mean the night's
on pre now as well um so
and if you do trade it's like you know
white does have a nice development
advantage i mean
if you don't trade you might have to
move a po you know it's it's just a
little bit uncomfortable
he does so yeah so can he get equalized
here this is the big question can he
exchange off that last bishop and or get
his king safe if he can draw yeah but
he's not there yet i mean black really
has to be super careful because i just
wanted to highlight a checkmate
okay and uh okay it won't happen but
it's just i'm just throwing it for
showing it for thrills and spills so
just say black develops bishop you know
out to c5
and the white knight jumps forward and
then the rook just comes in and defends
the square and it looks like yay
everything is good now my still might be
okay but just wanted to show the knight
could jump to the c7 and you couldn't
take it
because the rook comes to d8
and uh that would be unfortunate that's
actually how beth harmon won one one of
her games oh really
yeah
there's some danger still for the black
king if he's not accurate yeah it's a
famous this one's the opera mate isn't
it was famously played by morphy
against two geezers at the opera
yeah and i don't know their names the
count of brunswick was one of those
that's the one the count of bronze week
opera game so yes
the bar is uh jumping up for a minus
carlsen yeah i mean this is an
understandable move by prague but it
looks so slow
he stopped the white knight from jumping
forward to that square that uh kind of
it used in that variation ivanka
mentioned
but the knight's got another way as well
hasn't it now because
every every pawn move makes uh makes a
hole in your position and uh this last
pawn move the first thing my eyes are
drawn to is the square next to it
because uh that that wasn't that was
defended but it's not so maybe i can try
to get my knight around into that square
that's the first thing maybe there's
other options as well but you know it's
uh it's
still a couple of moves away from being
okay for prague yeah definitely the
black king's still stuck in the middle
normally that's okay in an end game but
there are enough pieces right now to
make that black king feel uncomfortable
all right it's a lot of drama inside the
arena today but uh there's also some
funny moments and of course hans niemann
is the man behind the funny moment
currently playing his match and game
three against liam but
he really had to go to the toilet so he
was allowed to
run
out of the arena
to do what he needed to do then he's
back now
one forest rock yeah
that would be a caption yeah for our
competition
[Laughter]
no i mean very quickly i know there was
a grand master who i won't mention the
name of and he he was trying to get his
ground well he wasn't a grandmaster at
the time he's playing a very important
game on a stage in a competition and he
needed to get a result a draw in his
game to get a grandmaster norm but he
really needed to go to the toilet he was
short on time on the stage
so he just got up and turned around and
went against the wall no
yeah yeah so that was bad and
to everyone's surprise um
he got his draw
i think but then but then he got kicked
out of the tournament so yeah it's
sensible so it is like yeah if you need
to go you need to go but sometimes you
should probably go in the toilet
sometimes more moral of my story
i don't know just just remember hearing
that story from you
but i have to say it's actually a very
real over-the-board dilemma like
especially when you don't have much time
and you know you're just like do you
risk it do you anyway let's like leave
this subject behind let's not run with
it yuri you don't have to go there
two moves on the board yeah meanwhile
talking you don't have to go there white
wants to come into the black camp now
he's jumped in with his knight first and
now magnus he's going to challenge
black's rook which wants to trade itself
off for white's rook but he's going to
use the white bishop to go and attack it
just looking on his screen there we go
we see a trade and now how does black
relieve the pressure white's rook is
ready to enter the seventh rank look at
those two white pieces they're kind of
fixed in uh in the heart of black's
position and it's as you mentioned simon
those black pawn moves that he made
earlier prague he's just allowed white
in he's allowed magnus to sneak in and
prank down to two and a half minutes
magnus over four minutes
the clock could become a factor
okay he's trying to use tactics here
prague to keep his position stable just
now the white rook cannot really enter
safely if the white rook goes in it will
either get captured or the piece is
defending it will be eliminated
maybe a bishop for nitrate if prague can
time it correctly will relieve some
pressure
but yeah it still feels like it's all
about magnus it's all about white and he
does love these positions catalan expert
but also when there's no risk when he
can kind of maneuver around set two or
three move traps here and there
either positional traps or kind of traps
to win
uh yeah it's
it just feels so close
to being something real for white but
maybe prague has still got it under
control just about
he's played it close though
close to the edge here prague
he's kept that pressure for out as he
magnus as you mentioned and he's just
finding move after move to make things a
bit difficult for uh prague to uh to
equalize and prague hasn't got there yet
i mean again it's not the end of the
world because prague has this equal pawn
formation and when you've got an equal
pawn formation symmetrical as pretty
much it's it's all about the pieces but
then we have to look at the pieces look
at black's rook it's still sleeping in
the corner uh if you have a castle you
allow white's brook to come nearly to
the top which is a great square what we
call the seventh rank
and white's minor pieces are really
annoying and they've got potential to
move now maybe i mean it's just little
things that are making this position
very difficult for prague but we saw we
saw him
in the last game you know i mean i think
his position last game was worse than
this
it was and he survived so he's got to do
the same again in this one and then he
gets the white pieces remember if magnus
wins this game he's won
the my miami miami what's my name
and he comes in he does come in and uh
this this move i think is so crafty
i mean
the black king cannot step forward now
and magnus's whole idea is that if black
castles then the knight will actually
step back and start attacking some pawns
and then he will get a favorable version
of uh
a rook
if if black decides to trade rook and
bishop versus rook and knight yeah let's
just show that ivanka because
actually pragnanda will be having
nightmares who haven't been having
flashbacks if this happens so uh if the
black king finally does castle castling
will move 25 pretty late attacking the
night now as you have mentioned the
knight will drop back attacking this
pawn you can trade it off but a
situation like this rook and bishop
against rook and knight
prague yesterday twice lost against duda
when he had a rook at night which he
would have now against the opponent's
rook and bishop so
yeah prague would not like that
assortment of pieces he will not like
that exchange he doesn't castle maybe he
just won't in this game instead he
pushes a pawn at least there's an escape
route for his king if he needs
but what is he doing here i mean i guess
his idea after the bishop steps back is
not to capture because then there would
be a nightfalk check and winning a pawn
instead i guess his idea is to actually
move his king out the way and just take
this knight although
some calculation is needed here after a
capture and the rook entering the
position maybe black's just about
surviving if white's rook takes this
pawn then the black knight will move and
double attack hitting this rook hitting
this bishop
it's becoming so complicated he's
holding it together with tactics prague
with deep calculation this is a six move
variation a five six move variation but
he's worked it out
quickly as well so quickly this is how
good he is prague the youngster and this
i had to take a while just talking
myself through that but he worked it out
in a few seconds yeah and again it's the
iceberg thing isn't it i mean this is
what great positional players are great
at tactics i mean this is something
we've seen time and time again and now
magnus is trying to still
keep hold of some of the holes he has by
swapping bishops but yeah i i mean
behind every good positional player is a
great tactical player i think it's it's
you know you can't just be a good
positional player about tactics because
to get good positions to get those
positional things you like you need to
use tactics
and what do we think of this last move
bishop why not just trade it off and
then i know it's better late than never
but you could castle or maybe could you
just bring the rook
this way try to sneak it in like if
white enters the seventh rank maybe you
can challenge
if you can swap these rooks off you'll
make the draw
still some work to be done okay he
castles immediately so he's actually
going for something similar to what we
just showed this is the current position
he finally castles on move 26
better late than never well what move
was it last game because he he's not
he's he's castling like pretty late you
know
didn't someone say to you that you never
castle david yeah magnus said that to me
wow
we talked about hammer earlier with this
look alike i once casted a move 37
against hammer that was my nice castle
queen did you win yeah the problem is
casting wasn't even a good move but i
just had to do it because it was so
flashy
and he nearly jumped off his chair he
forgot it was possible meanwhile um
magnus
okay it's rookie bishop versus rook and
knight prague lost two games with that
yesterday and now he's attacking this
weak pawn
i guess the reason brook bishop worked
better than rook and knight is because
rook and bishop together they basically
do the same job as a queen
and they move in the same way at queen
wood rook and knight just don't combine
as well for some reason
okay big threat guard this pawn and when
there's pawns on both sides of the board
as well uh that's you know if you think
about bishops and endings when you have
pawns on the left and right queen side
and king side the bishop is generally
better because it can
basically aim at both sides in one move
right you can control both sides of the
ball but the knight
it can't do that because it takes a long
time to get from one side to the other
therefore the knight is very good when
there's pawns only on one side of the
board that's when it's generally better
than the bishop so it's just worth
remembering if you get to an ending
about these small things and there was a
very famous ending bobby fischer had
bishop versus knight um and i can't
remember his opponent but um we see a
pawn sack here first of all
yeah we see a really uh surprising pawn
sacrifice white's rook wins upon but
prague dives in now with his rook so
he's hitting the queenside pawns over
here but maybe these can be defended and
uh this pawn in the middle is at least
defended by white's rook
wondering what happens if for example
the bishop drops back to defend these
pawns
if the bishop drops back the knight will
just spring forward and then the white
rook gives a check yeah uh the black
king can move it's another check however
i mean but prague is seeing everything
so quickly but i don't know i'm scared
for him he's a pawn down this pawn is
attacked maybe he can hold it together
but he's really living life on the edge
here
yeah rag okay he instead brings his king
in uh maybe this is the best way of
hitting the rook which has to retreat
i guess his idea at some point is to
start launching these pawns forward to
make the white bishop feel uncomfortable
i mean if he holds this what a defense
just active defending not materialistic
at all
and he's going for your plan david and
uh it's suddenly becoming a slightly
awkward for white as well
because you don't really want to be
letting go of that contact with the uh
those pawns on the left yeah these pawns
might drop off prague he's opened up the
game it's a three result game now
magnus may be having to be careful both
players around the one minute mark i'm
expecting to practice continue pushing
some pawns maybe the black a pawn
yeah i mean again he's a pawn down just
like he was in the last game but if he
defended that he can defend this and the
computer
approves of his sacrifice
it's so mature i mean that wouldn't have
come across my mind i've got to admit
um maybe if you give me half an hour but
prague spotted it in a few seconds and
now he's kicking away white's rook he
really wants to try and trap this white
bishop with his pawns
white rook's got to be careful where it
goes to
but it is a pawn
and
if if white can just uh maintain that
pawn and unravel his pieces somewhat
then you know it is a pawn up in the
ending
uh just a little update i mean i i think
we're all kind of rooting for hands
to get something out this tournament
right and it's one and a half all in
that match like i think like yesterday
one game to go he just he's just got to
avoid losing that last game hands and
you're going to get some money for uber
eats
can he do it
so just uh you know i think we've got
some secret hands fans around you know
fans hounds fans
reminds me of all those rhymes and
chants we had yesterday yeah but uh
meanwhile magnus is consolidating that
white king has come back and it's
kicking the black rook out of his camp
the black rook has to retreat there was
nowhere else safe to go if it stepped
across one square to the left the white
king would have followed it chased it
out
this is starting to look really bad
isn't it for black i mean it you know
now
now that that that rook has been yeah
supporting down that rook has been
forced back it's
he's starting to get his pieces um
working well together uh magnus at the
moment which is bad news for prague i
think he just lost a bit of time prague
he pushed a pawn hit the white rook but
he had to lose some time with the black
king if he just continued pushing his
pawns on the left side earlier i didn't
really see how magnus was going to kind
of unravel
but now oh
giving a second pawn away prague this is
just desperation you know the clock is
playing a factor and also his position
is just falling apart
there is maybe a small trap
i'm not sure whether it works or not but
if white goes now and grabs the pawn in
front of it then black will push his
b-pawn and trap that white bishop so
magnus had to keep his rook the white
rook on the fourth rank
uh there we go it keeps everything
defended prague wins one pawn back but
still a pawn down and now the white
bishop activates that white bishop
dominates the black knight
it's gonna be uphill struggle for the
young indian could we be seeing the
decisive game of the ftx crypto cup and
i like the way magnus is playing just
look at it instead of supporting that
bishop he retreats it and just starts
over protecting some squares and look at
that bishop as well it's going to be
targeting the g5 pawn
and there's so much danger for prague
for danger yeah i fully expect white to
push a pawn forwards i mean a great way
to play against knights if you ever get
in a situation like this especially when
you've got the bishop versus the knight
is to limit the squares that your
opponent's knight can move into there's
only one forward square that knight can
move into and you can cover that square
of your pawn so cover the squares your
opponent's knight with your pawns this
is just a very typical strategy to
improve the position there might well be
better moves i mean even bishop takes
pawn is a little tactic that
could work but um a simple move would
just be to cover that night uh and this
is just a very safe pawn up now
with and it's a good pawn as well yeah
yeah shades of the last game shades of
the previous game where magnus was a
pawn up there prague defended it but
this one is even harder because it's not
just a pure rook and portland game it's
also this bishop versus knight
conundrum yeah i mean imagine prague
losing three games twice yesterday
against judah one game today rook and
bishop vs rook and knight yep something
to work on definitely something to work
on hasn't magnus read the script of
today and i think he's read it i mean
come on magnus you're supposed to leave
it until the last game and let the young
kid win
so maybe
is there some chances now because magnus
is offered a rook trade
and that does change the nature of the
game i mean i was
wasn't expecting that i was expecting
the rooks to stay on the board
yeah i was expecting them to stay on the
board as well when you have rook and
bishop they worked so well together
white's rook was on a nice square i
liked simon's move just kind of lock in
that night black's knight wasn't really
going anywhere
spectacular now
he's still a pawn up and it is a pass
pawn white's e porn could be the
uh the eventual winner of this game
but
some chances of black creating a
fortress on the light squares black
needs a miracle here he needs to somehow
trade off all of white's pawns apart
from maybe the white a pawn
the white a pawn if you look at it on
the left corner it promotes on a light
square therefore even if black loses the
rest of his army if white only has that
pawn and his bishop black's king could
just hide away and it would be a draw so
there is some kind of long-term dream
for prague to save this one but
20 seconds
pawn down
difficult end game worst minor piece
yeah facing the world champion yeah and
he has a weak pawn and i did wonder
about this particular move just get rid
of it trade off some pawns
and uh like you say
pin all hope on a light square blockade
i mean if you could get rid of the the
pawns on the on the queen side draw yeah
uh but you know it's the the the one
hope i think prank has is there's not
many pawns left
and he's got to try to try somehow to
exchange off a couple more pawns i think
but magnus has a very clear plan here
using his king not just to help his
passport and go through but to
move over to the queen side and try to
win another pawn and
technically this has to be said is a
winning ending for white um five seconds
for prague yeah he has to make a move
and i thought maybe he could just wait
with pawns and okay he waits for the
knight he's
so calm he's barely moving look brag
he's just kind of got his mouth just
side on from him and he went down to
three seconds there and wow just calmly
made his move and i feel there might be
a zugswang coming up here bishop b4 for
example there we go and black is in
zugus wang meaning whatever black plays
here he's going to allow the white king
to come forwards zig zwang is you have
to give something away basically and now
well you don't have to do it now but the
white king can start coming towards
those pawns
um
you could all restrict the night he's
restricted the knight first
and uh this is just very bad isn't it
now i mean this is the strategy you want
to adopt especially if you're facing a
knight the white bishop controls the
dark squares the white pawns control the
light squares black's knight has nowhere
good to go dances into the center but
um yeah simon said zugswang is going to
be the theme of the rest of the game
eventually we will see a situation where
black's knight and king both stuck
and okay he's keeping it together with
some night forks some dancing nights
night checks if the white king starts
running towards those black pawns there
will be a nasty double attack with the
black knight but it's not going to hold
forever and uh
should be winning now he's doing the
best he can i mean you know don't give
up hope yet i mean if you're a prag fan
he you know there's not much material
but you are playing the best end game
player in the world and you've got a
losing end game
which is tough he's defended one
maybe he can defend this one too yeah
okay white's pawn steps forward i'm
slightly surprised by that one just
because it felt nice to keep that one in
reserve not commit that pawn white's
pawn is potentially a weakness now if
the white king runs away over where it
wants to go better look at him
he's got that bishop move
the king can't move so the knight is
forced
to just concede ground this is why i
wanted to keep white's pawn back where
it started because now at least it's a
target for black agreed now if the white
king runs the white pawn in the center
drops so this is given this is this move
seems to give him pranks some chances
magnificent and uh definitely yeah i
think there's
he's maybe back in with a shout out um i
mean if he defends this it's just like
oh my word's incredible and the other
thing that might work in prague's favor
is if you look at the the pawn right in
the left-hand side of whites
it's queening if you get it up on the
light square and there's some endings
because you've got a dark square bishop
which uh um will also give black some
hope just a very small technical thing
there but what's happening here now is
it can he can he keep this blockade
it's still not going to be easy white's
king does have a path towards those
black pawns
so once bishop's attacked i'm expecting
it to move
maybe to the square where it's defended
by this pawn there we go the white
bishop and white porn are kind of just
going to keep each other
uh cozy they're comfortable and white's
king is going to try and do the dirty
work
it's still not easy the king is ready to
come isn't it black's king
maybe it's time for black to
push some pawns and he goes for it
and i'm thinking if you can push the a
pawn two squares and give
you know give white a doubled a pawn
he's trying yeah then maybe there's hope
in that end game that you guys have
referenced
okay he's taken one of white's two
remaining pawns but magnus stepping back
now he's going to try and create an
eternal swang uh okay the black king can
move though can you take that pawn with
white i mean can you i mean the idea is
to trap this black knight in the stable
yeah
i mean i i think i think you're
threatening to go bishop takes pawn i
think the king of pawn ending is just
winning isn't it we have to show this
this is the winning idea if black just
waits now with his king bishop takes
pawn if the knight and bishop get traded
white will win this pawn will eventually
become a queen but if you remove this
pawn one more move and black would draw
if he could just bring his knight down
and take this pawn it's a draw but white
can drop his bishop back lock this
knight in its stable uh the bishop
controls these squares the knight is
trapped and simply white's king is going
to come back and take it
game over
it's a very simple plan he can play oh
no he hasn't played
he's also trying to he's found another
way i think to win and this is uh
to move his king towards his past pawn
and shepard shepard it through yeah so
maybe you play it now do you take this
pawn now with the bishop uh maybe that's
the winning idea okay the king drops
back
it's just zookswang unfortunately you're
right simon if the knight moves this
pawn falls if the king moves then the
white king is going to step forward and
start supporting its pawn
prague is fighting for his life but
magnus is winning this position or
should be winning this position and
remember if magnus wins this game he's
secured at least tie breaks he will be
the winner of the fdx crypto cup
with a win in this game
hope hanging in a very thin thin thread
for the indian fans
he needs night forks he needs some
tricks he needs to get rid of white's
two remaining pawns at the cost of his
night there is one trick though i'm not
sure that white can go and grab that
pawn because if it does the knight will
jump
into the e2 square
yup
still it's still you know you can still
go wrong here still a lot of fight left
in the position
i mean how many times does magnus go
wrong in endings like this so it's so
rare um and the time situation well okay
prague has done brilliantly with only
five seconds left and uh magnus getting
a little bit short and he's not making
any progress yet is he going to go back
to that other plan now
possibly we've seen the simplest way to
win maybe
yeah it looks like he's going back to
square one and he's going to try the
line the variation that we did show
a few moments ago
is this winning that is the key
i just don't see a move for black white
is just going to take this board
this is just a simple way to win i think
and uh yeah you can see his body
language there he he he's this this
night stable um is just such a good
technique when you've got the bishop
versus the knight well worth remembering
and uh i don't see any escape now for
prague yeah two threats white will
either move the bishop back and trap
that black knight or the second threat
is to just defend his pawn and
two pawns you can't stop them both
it's a hopeless position for prague
oh he came so close uh yeah one slip in
this game and magnus just
magnus was doing magnus things wasn't he
you know he's uh
probing his advantage as always and
grinding it out that's why he's an
in-game wizard grind master as you say
david
and let's remember if you want to grind
like the master himself he has released
apparently one of the best chessboard
courses of all time with david howell
and you can purchase that course over at
chessball and he's won
there we go wow it's over and a reaction
by magnus carlsen he is the winner of
the ftx crypto cup with this win the
match isn't over they will play another
game a game for